um is there anything you want to do that
you haven't done yet it seems like you
you all your dreams seem to have come
true yeah i can't i don't have well i
honestly like
it it's been
a pretty crazy last decade and and um
it's hard to consider taking on more
projects
so anything i take on now has got to be
really more passionate than
than something that i just want you know
that we're hoping to make money from and
so um
what would i like to do i i would love
to do this thing we're doing in vegas
i'd love to take that else like to do
that internationally
wow because we're doing a whole weekend
skate music sort of festival that's
gonna be great the fans will be playing
so the bands will be playing live yeah
explain to me how this festival is we're
we're bringing my my personal ramp the
one that you've probably seen right in a
big warehouse we're bringing that to
vegas right we're going to have a
a professional competition on it
throughout the weekend we're going to
have master of what we call
legends demo so
people like cristiano soy steve
caballero myself uh skating
is that an announcement that we're
hearing first
um
i don't know we're doing oh yeah yeah
you are actually let's just make it a
little
can't say the bands but but yes
the first time we've heard about the
skaters going to be there
i want some breaking news on that that's
it yes so
i mean
and people that have grown in the 80s
know those names absolutely um and then
we're going to have a video game element
obviously people playing tony hawk's pro
skater
and on big screens outside yeah that's
amazing yeah and then uh we're going to
what else are we having there do you
play the game do you play the video game
yeah are you good at the game i'm good
because that's a different thing myself
howie well back to boney [ __ ]
whatever when is your when is your
festival
uh may
11th to 13th and when does it go on sale
um it's on sale it's on sale and you
have not announced it
may 16th
how was the festival
did you enjoy yourself it was the best i
wish i could tell you what bands played
but i can't yeah this is too weird it
airs in two weeks
can you we'll have the bands announced
then yeah oh
so nothing you've done so then we could
do like one week
who you're gonna give me the skaters
who you're booking we could do one week
we could do this next week let's do this
one next week
will the bands have been uh announced
next week really no next tuesday you
don't know it's you well i i know but
but there is a group that's booking the
bands caroline just texted me i told you
just to pipe in and tell us you're in
the new jackass movie i know yeah yeah
yeah
yeah yes you're in the new jackass i am
yes is that an announcement
i don't know sure well not if caroline
knew probably not so are you you're
doing this this is your festival when
you say it's your festival are you
working with live nation are you working
poland
okay
and and is this uh
is this something that you hope to be
making a lot of money with or you hope
to be annual or um i would hope that we
would be able to take this format and do
it in other cities
this year again this year
like all of this like an oz fest kind of
thing yes yes and i would like to do it
internationally i think that if you ask
me like what is what do you aspire to it
would be something like that what is the
weirdest place not like astro world
right
right not like astro world
yeah not like that okay
just making sure thank you jackie
honestly we would have a very limited
ticket sales
how many people we wanted to be intimate
i think that the
we're going to sell out somewhere around
5 000
oh that's a small festival but that's
great right because they'll be close
enough to see the games and to see you
and to see the older version of your
face
[Music]
you